[Musik]
schließlich und herzlich willkommen zur
sternstunde religion zitiert schon einig
ihre synagoge sie heute schon mal eine
muslimische gebaut teilt nun oder sieht
sie schon mal die der zehn meditation
der big sie und herr nicht so recht
gewusst wie noch zur haute die
verunsicherungen fünf männer und frauen
im tv experiment wege vor der religion
wo zurzeit hier auf sf1 läuft und so hat
angefangen
[Musik]
hatte johannes richtung der zweifler
muslim unternehmer das bbt europäische
podest schaffte bis schwarz
aber ich studiere jetzt durch johannes
und zu einer plötzlich willkommen wie
abgemacht dass mit solchen schutz vor
name so wie es auch interessante wege
der religionen tv ist gerade 16
die angst vor negativen reaktionen das
ist sicher bin ich mir ganz gut dran ist
überlegen bevor der zug sei damit machen
was wieder vorausgegangen das ist ganz
viele reaktionen wird grund dar und sie
sich negativ aus schutz für diese arbeit
wurde er schlug sie wobei aber so wenn
wir bei den wänden der haben das nur mit
dem vornamen gerade wenn man so ein
spezieller vor wir haben es ja es ist ja
schon respektabel fernsehschauen auf ein
zimmer weiß nicht genau was letztlich
den usa und wie immer dargestellt
zuerst einmal das 80 und ja wir stellen
unsere ganze religionsgemeinschaft
dauern und das sollen jetzt alle werde
mit ihnen identifizieren von vornherein
klar dass so der so kontrovers
diskutiert
die studierte philosophie und religion
im haus der religionen in diese
praktisch bei die sozusagen mit einem
professionellen zugang zu religion hat
wie ich das von husic sie für das amt
ich glaube es ist nicht voraussetzung
sei aber es ist sicher so wie nichts mit
barrois sind schon gut gesucht wurde war
ein gewisses gewisses vorwissen
mitbringen oder zumindest in trance und
das gras sondern offenheit es sehr oft
darum entweder schon verbunden und fast
alle aus dagmara ist eigentlich schon
fit professionell oder so aber ich
glaube sogar wir alle eben wo es
überdurchschnittliches vorwissen
mitbrachte als ich das vermissen sie für
das überhaupt mit neun kreis gespielt
aber haben denn nur die einfache frage
an anrichten
ich glaub nicht das vorwissen
voraussetzung ist aber dass sie dann im
rahmen dieser machen das schon sehr
kurve wo man bis eine bestimmte gerade
sensibilisiert dass der interreligiöse
und interkulturelle frage aber langt und
entsprechend sich viele angehörige der
dialog asymmetrie russische dialogs ohne
zusicherung geschafft werden
schwierige frage besprochen und
diskutiert durchschnittszuschauer
bald danach auch metro sprecher
jetzt stelle ich mir vor sich mit
religion oder so exponiert ist deshalb
verständlich was man sich persönliche
motivation sie damit zu machen man nicht
selbst mal davon gehört einfach klarheit
wo ein potash für mich einmalig also
kann schon muslimische und jedes alter
bekannt das ist nicht einfach
so kann als lehrer und und dann einfach
das setting das mit zwei wochen lang aus
ich sehe jetzt zügig grund zum gewicht
kann während seine mutter und hat auch
nicht kameras oder ohne fernsehen weil
auf der siegstrecke ein neues format
umsätze und andere sitzen personen
lernen kontext sieht sarkozy
verantwortung spürt ich sauber sehr
stark dafür einsetzen dass gerade junge
muslimische stimme mit zu worttrennung
in der öffentliche diskurs und
entsprechend an ihn nachher show wunder
also wenn ich schon mal so eine
möglichkeit bekommen der musiker
begriffen sind vorbereitet
es geht also ich glaube es einzige
wirklich vorbereiten
es ist dass ich im vorfeld zu stehen für
das projekt paten und das kloster das
andere kollege mehr zeit an sie werden
quasi zwischen gbagbos im gewand
unterstützen so viel mehr vorbereitet so
groß wie die anderen informiert also ist
es sie dass sie nicht vorbereitet habe
ja schon viele gespräche geführt mit
anderen muslimischen personen
auch die bestätigung haben dass sie das
so in ordnung finden wir sie dazu haut
sie zogen mit personen war schon länger
im interreligiösen und interkulturellen
dialogs sedo thematik damit die beste
weise fast dass michaela geküsst war die
andere für sie der unterschied ist
wirklich sehr wenig informationen zu der
andere vier bewohnerinnen und bewohner
gar nicht wüssten dass der ofen hand zu
geld als männer die wird die anderen
läden und gleichzeitig verkündet wird
ausdrücklich und muslimen und der
atheist und so bietet ist es überhaupt
möglich dann fetting so ganz unbefangen
ja also ja es ist wirklich so dass ich
mir dass ich möchte ich aus meinem sieg
heraus
thomas gehören für mich ist ich hab
schon recht gut geschafft
oh ja es ist ein wie einfach strom kann
also ich persönlich kann jetzt leben und
so aber das setting ist anders hat man
im laufenden projekt anfangs extrem viel
und religion gegangen
sprach und geschlossener wie jeder zeit
in mein carlo schmid hat ganz tief über
religionsführer und beschloss dann eine
persönlich wollte weil du auch in
mainaschaff sowie das thema ganz anders
sieht es mit dem motto schwieriger die
sache miteinander diskutieren und das
ist erst möglich wenn man wirklich auch
gemeinsame boot und dabei und ein
schönes haus persönlich besser
kennenlernt und jetzt aber über die
religion kultur hinaus miteinander im
gespräch ist und deswegen das moped
nachher show dazu geführt dass man
garantie vor der wege und schwierige
themen konstruktiv miteinander
diskutiert und andere sieht so begrüßt
tui zum anderen netzen sagte wenn jetzt
das und das fragen wir uns wieso man da
mit liebe zueinander kann also sein dass
die schwierige thema mode religionen
weder betraf und sind es schwierige
thema betraf das für mich sind das ist
legitim und religionsgemeinschaften teil
persönlich sehr öffnen
es lohnt sich oft der öffentlichen
diskussionen über religion und soziale
themen freuen
das geschlechterverhältnis
leitungsstruktur bedeutung von fritz
sieht es wirklich die themen wohnsitz
als religiöser mensch aber das auf junge
menschen der generation das die themen
wie ich beschäftige mich beschäftige sie
haut vor augen mit dem bezug auf dem hof
vor der religionen vor dem herd sieht es
so themen und fragen ja immer wieder
dass beantworten
aber ich glaube jetzt zum beispiel
glatzkopf durch thema das ist innerhalb
von der muslimischen gemeinschaft und
muslimische frauen viel weniger das
thema außerhalb davor ist und das ist so
stark wie die medi und so weiter
diskutiert wird oder aber jede form
einig das ist nicht so
innerhalb von der musikgemeinschaft und
gerade junge muslimische frau entwendet
als rockerbraut greifen die themen wo
verursache sei wichtig ist das minus
damit auseinandersetzen
aber so starkes thema persönlich würde
mich persönlich war das einfach gewisse
themen extrem breit gerade die medien
ich glaube einfach hinter assoziationen
liegt gerade wenn sie jetzt katholische
gehören das war schlag wertlos ist immer
fix damit verbinden also zum beispiel
also ein missbrauchsfall
genau das sind so ja
und also auch geknickter wie sicher
glaubt dass sharp sony viel sekt das
gerade tanzen muslime in der schweiz gab
extreme innere
eigentlich habe ich den knopf
staatlicher die nichts zu sagen haben
dass max themen reduziert wird kann man
das eine oder andere perspektive über
leid und habe genau einer stunde
die hat mir ein ford-sprecher zeit
eigentlich beide eigentlich geschützten
bereich auch wenn immer wieder die
gleichen themen die gleichen fragen ob
sie weiter wie goethe mit dann um die
ecke sagt eigentlich muss man trotzdem
auferstanden ist haben die wir werden
viel appetit ist panik ich glaube mehr
ist schwierig als auslandserfahrung für
kontext dem motiv frage stellt wird
politisches schwierig wenn jeder fragt
schon bestimmt die vorurteile mit denen
sie und ihr personal fragt eigentlich
die vorurteile nicht bestätigt dass sie
antwort also gerade zum beispiel ständig
vor der frau im islam des von ihm
erwarten musste zu positionen sich an
jenes antwort ja ich finde das schon
problematisch wenn sie die muslimische
gemeinschaft ist also hier weiter weg
vor uns bis täglich stellen zwischen
mann und frau war leistete gemeinschaft
dienen genau gleich wie sie an der
gemeinschaft ist genau gleich wie soll
die schweizerische gesellschaft ist und
über tommy hilfiger als antwort ja der
islam dieses problem und andere sitzen
ja beantwortet damit von michael bisping
oscars als muslimische frau erachtet die
religion eigentlich eher herausstellt
situation mehr aus frohwitter entwickle
meine fähigkeiten entfalten
und eben aus antwort ja das spezielle v
also irgendwie kamen garnier also sie
ist nach agadir ich bekannt wurde
jetzt wünsche ich mir vertrauen das ist
ehrlicher die frage gestellt wo möglich
ist möchte zu erleben
frage und antwort und allgemeine
religion ist es richtig spannend wird es
aber erst wenn man sie in die
komfortzone verlagert und die zeremonie
oder meine gepackt von einer anderen
religion teilnimmt nur minimal und wege
von der religionen
[Musik]
kriminalität für unschöne konzentriert
meine gedanken und vor allem jeder
arabische rezitation verdächtig aber
jetzt wirklich ein einziger blick ja
viele die islam und die islamische
gemeinschaft sprach mit ihm
wird's richtig sinnlich
danke gott
ja da hätte was ist da jeweils den kopf
gegangen wenn die gewalt oder die
zeremonie vor anderen religionen teil
geschieht nichts also gerade die moschee
für mich ist sie glaube jetzt machen hat
sich auf die eigenen sicher nicht wie
sie aus frau ich habe als ich das jetzt
schon nicht so sehr persönliches auch
wenn das so öffnet und ja ich glaube
gerade gerade in der maschine wirklich
zum beispiel hat die ehrfurcht vor
gehabt wo man auch keine schlechten
extrem starker fahrer
und ja ich glaube sich das
grundsätzliche halten sie vom respekt
aber ich glaube das stört ist in einem
anderen staat zum hut trug wurde respekt
vor anderen religionen und speziell
ausschnitt jetzt wie die buddhistische
zeremonie teil nahe eigentlich die
richtige ausdruck oder ich mir das auch
nie beobachtet oder fragt sich die ganze
zeit was machst du eigentlich mit und
ausdauertraining was was bewegt einen
sommer lang im buddhismus ist also wenig
nach ihr spezieller foxi womöglich
selbst für sich gemacht also es ist also
mit hey ob die meditationen mitgemacht
meditation macht und mit gespür für sehr
wichtig ist und entsprechend von mikro
geführt dass sie der moment mit mir
teilen
gleichzeitig ist es aber schon das ist
für mich besonders freut ist eine art
ritual doris führer verdammt
also aber ich fühle mit geld darf sie
aber das ist wirklich es ist für mich
persönlicher sakrale bedeutung einfach
weil ich mit ihm identifizieren momente
da wurde nicht viel die gewissen
situationen richtig unwohl hat mir das
eigentliche sandig frage sie das meer
ist zum beispiel ptpt szene da auch ein
bisschen butterfahrt so man ist jetzt
eben große freiheit dem ex mann hat da
ein messer peter meditationen mitmachen
will und wohl ein knet im sinn für das
web seite steigt freilich respektvollen
umgang falle wenn man sich die sieht
sehr diplomatisch sehr respektvoll
miteinander umgegangen
ich darf jetzt teil von einem sexy
unterwäsche oder la petite aus ihrem
alltag also ich glaube sie im alltag die
tv show also verdammt harnik die chance
sehr für authentische gefunden aus was
maschine jetzt vor der religion mit rund
um personal sensibilisiert sie ihr stück
wie offen sie will der dialog man halt
nicht und geht es um ca als polarisierer
innerhalb von der weg es ist wird der
umgang eine konstruktive dialog
miteinander zu führen
und egal ob es so dass das bitte
mehrheit von der manager boni geht es im
auto
das ist für mich das abbild von der
möglichkeit aus
aber gerade das sind alles sehe jetzt
bewegen wo interessiert so
sensibilisiert zu oft wachsen sie aber
das entspricht ja nicht die realität im
auto
also kann man das eine schließe ich
glaube in der öffentlichkeit hier stehen
wir wo polarisiert das sind immer extrem
wenige extrem lüttich stimmen und ja ich
glaube es ganz viel glück macht das
wirklich
er glaube einfach 40 schlagen wenn es
innerhalb des g toni kroos an dass
vorurteile und so und ja ich glaube wenn
du merkst also wenn du mehr haben wir
jetzt noch mal luft zeigt das problem
ist so benannt das lager oder mit einer
zugabe aber ich glaube ganz vernarrt in
der schweiz passiert dass ich glaube
nicht dass jetzt die meist streng
muslimischen familie restliche familie
und benannt war nicht irgendwer mal
gerade noch geschafft krach hat die
ganze zeit also das gerät das stück zwar
irgendwann fried der mädchen so
vermittelt wird jetzt hat auch die wege
konstruktion und die gesellschaft hätten
klar die mehrheiten und minderheiten
wozu das ganze land besondere situation
dass schon etwas hat schon als thema wo
man angesprochen haut schon bruce
entstanden sie das ist aber so
asymmetrie der gesellschaft und gibt
dadurch die mannschaft dialog und es ist
weniger das einzige muslimische
persönlich für seine religion verdammt
ist das sehr viel besser zum ausdruck
rosa belegte dialog auf augenhöhe und
andere systeme borja nativ vorkasse oder
gesellschaft und auf oder
mehrheitsgesellschafters stück mit
nominal besprochen hätte aufgefallen
thomas als religiöse sehr stark mit
seinen fragen ist das umgekehrt
ja also das verhältnis so eine weile
ansprache war sehr nett der realwelt
entspricht das der erste große termin
bereits entgegen interreligiösen und der
mensch ich glaube dass ich frauen glaubt
ihr dass vielmehr auseinandersetze
gesellschaft zwischen religion nicht
religion
das gab es schon da so über das größte
frage wirklich mehr für religiöse liegt
und kaka oder thomas vatter hat
gestanden dass er zeit sich über
unterschiede und gemeinsamkeiten der
religionen im nachstellung schnitt sehen
wir jetzt was euch seine aufgefallen ist
und parallele zwischen judentum und
islam und maschinen interessant ist so
dass man ohne konkret und trauer in
oberhof hat das ist aber nicht meine
sowas kann auch sie dass meine frau und
frau in hannover und mannheim hockey
oder rechts und links mit einfach hier
willst einen up training machen
in kristallform das könnte das ganz
unterschiedlich - pflanzen ist im
philharmonischen der frage warum es ist
ja selbstverständlich
es ist eigentlich ein relativ simples
und während dem gebiet geht es darum
dass man sich fokussiert und moves
gespräch mit mit godzilla dass jetzt ein
ich finde unterschiede und
gemeinsamkeiten der religionen aber es
geht ja die unterschiede und
gemeinsamkeiten zu viele
persönlichkeiten also zwischen ich hätte
da es erlaubt die andere unterwegs oder
kompetent ich glaube der ist wichtig
sich bewusst machen dass er persönlich
number four sie der religion bei fluss
tisch und praktisch sondern das ist ganz
viele unterschiedliche sachen sie wo
mehr aus personen mehr aus
entsprechend dann könnte ich es mir
schon ganz unterschiedliche personen ob
sie einfach auf grund fest
aufgrund von rad und wissen aufgewachsen
was wir heute machen beruflich und so
weiter verdammt sind unterschiedliche
personen mit weder gemeinsamkeit
gehässig das ist sicher da sitzt
religiöse oder religiöse sowie das im
auftag umstandes kreis genauen blick auf
das schon eine gemeinsamkeit dass du
überhaupt was alles aber nicht mehr viel
machen dass er thomas es um alles was er
fest von 60 cent wir mindestens das gab
das ist wo grundsatz auf vielleicht
schaffe ich es erst recht diese
gemeinschaft welt vielleicht seine
thematisieren ich versuche alles
behaupten gar nicht an das ist gar nicht
so wichtig so klar die linien zahl
könnte die vorstelle ist eine wg aber
glaubst du musst also gerade jetzt
meines runtergefahren meinem chef teil
wird zusammen wohnen denn dann müsste
ich mich an die mit rohem fleisch dann
auch denn ich glaube ja das war das
frühstück das eben einfache aber
grundsätzlich als mit den android market
für den projekttag super also schön
stefan raab hatte vermachen
ich hoffe dass ich so in zukunft wieder
ohne hoffe wirklich dass mit dass mit
einem höheren betrag lässt für das
friedliche zusammenleben hoffe so
anderes büro stück mitnehmen grad medien
schaffen
dioxin ist so möglichkeit ist eine
chance wenn wir religion auf die a8 und
wie es dasteht und designqualität ist
gerade im bezug auf ihre religion schon
so dass man es schaffen uns
weiterentwickeln
das noch wichtig
die harry potter stars musliminnen und
muslime liegt jedes schweiz zeige dass
die früheste gesellschaft es mit da ganz
ganz sieht jahrzehnte showdown mit
schweizer bürgerinnen und bürger sie und
da gibt es ja auch wirklich von
muslimischer seite immer wieder
kampagnen wie zum beispiel die aktuelle
slim stories was muslime sind ganz
normale menschen ganz normale personen
künstlerinnen und künstler bbk dass man
das thema religion müsse medien anders
behandelt man die die letzte von vier
folgen wird nächsten stück zeigt und
alle vier folgen sie es auf der website
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich dass du
dass ich sie die hannes und seine ist
das verhältnis zu dir ist ambivalent die
eine die andere erklären sie zu
familienmitgliedern und in indien war
die grösste sogar verehrt und religiöse
gründe
hier seht ihr jetzt gefallen der kult um
heilige tiere schöne dritten advent
schöne sonnig
[Musik]